[Musik]
peter bleibt noch eine woche zeit sieben
tage um den kampf seines lebens zu
bestreiten
[Musik]
hier in kenia will peter regierungschef
einer provinz werden außergewöhnliche
daran ist nicht nur diese mütze
normalerweise durch die wahrlich keine
müsse aber war der anfang der woche
gewarnt
[Musik]
vor kurzem noch putzte der 58-jährige
die böden von parkhäusern und
shoppingzentren im kanton thurgau ist
hauswand
er kam vor 24 jahren in die schweiz und
besitzt einen schweizer pass
was er hier gelernt hat könne er in
kenia gut gebrauchen sagt er
beispielweise der genauigkeit sauberkeit
das hilft es soviel zu besuch bei einer
der töchter von peters seine vier
erwachsenen kinder aus einer früheren
ehe leben alle in der schweiz seit zwei
jahren ag eine neue partnerin barbara
vor
sie arbeitet bei einer bank in der
ausbildung bald heißt es für alle
abschied nehmen den opfert zieht es
zurück nach kenia gesagt seine 24 jahre
in der schweiz hätten ihm gezeigt wie
man die dinge anpacken können ihn
brauche es hier mehr als in der schweiz
ich hab ich schon aber der dass der
regierung mit der business von der lieth
marke kann das finde ich einfach
bedenkenlos größte problem
dieselbe hat auch ein paar probleme
beispielsweise mit diesem geschäft das
ihm längst hätte steine liefern sollen
die steine hatte schon vor der wahl
gekauft um in seinem heimatdorf ein
gemeindezentrum zu errichten
immer sagt er man muss sie ja
unterschiedlich hofmiller es wieder
abbezahlt und geliefert ende ja das ist
einfach das problem mit dem lied ja er
sei kein halber schweizer präzisierte
peter cheret als die kamera schon
auswahl gefühle sich zu mindestens 60
prozent als schweizer jazz wahlkampf
findet in einer entlegenen provinz statt
wo es kaum infrastruktur gibt schon gar
keine bankomaten
deshalb muss der arbeit aus dem thurgau
noch geld holen dass er unterwegs
benötigen wird
das ist nicht normal
das vierte schweizer franken
und wie lang lang da landet nur heute
4000 franken in einer region wo die
meisten menschen von weniger als einen
franken pro tag leben müssen mit dem
geld müsste sich viel kaufen lassen nur
was der distrikt in dem pkw zur wahl
steht als ganze er hat etwa die fläche
des kanton waadt einige von jazz
wahlhelfern begleiten uns es ist eine
fahrt in eine andere welt
140.000 einwohner des distrikts leben
verstreut in kleinen siedlungen von
meist nur ein paar hundert menschen
1989 sind wie robert betrag hätte wohl
kokosnuss der pflanze geht wird aber wir
sind ja werkzeuge diese einwohner
scheinen den weggezogenen nicht
vergessen zu haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
naja
die einheimischen feiern ihn wie einen
könig sogar eine band ist gekommen
erst später wird klar dass diese zu
peters wahl auftritt gehört ein wagen
mit lautsprechern und plakaten ist
vorausgefahren aus den einheizer folgte
man die zuhören sie alle gekommen sind
[Applaus]
hat man hat ihr habt genug gelitten
wegen der dummheit der politiker die
zukunft werdet ihr profitieren der
abfahrt entpuppt sich als begnadeter
redner
er zündet ein verbales feuerwerk von
dreiviertel stunden am montag müssen
einfach alle kommen dann erledigen wir
die sache und eine woche nach der wahl
werdet ihr schon resultate sehen was
folgt sind weitere redner die für peter
bewerben die leute werden wie du licht
zu eines haben sie zeit und sonst was
braucht liter meister am meisten bürger
phase wasser also wasser fallen
und dann natürlich hasse
unterbeschäftigung beschäftigung es
hatte keine spital es hat nicht es hat
absolut nicht sklave durchschnitt wo
nichts ist kann mit wenig geholfen
werden
ein paar scheine gibt er den leuten hier
damit diese an halbfertigen schulhaus
weiterbauen können
doch es bleibt nicht bei der einen
spende wie sich bald herausstellen
sollte im laufe des tages verteilte geld
als wäre er ein großes an leute am
strassenrand an andere die ihm helfen
oder auch bloß zu hören und vor allem
tut er es mit einer irritierenden
selbstverständlichkeit und in aller
öffentlichkeit wie hier bei diesem
lehrer kongress zustimmen
ja fahrlässig eine andere hoffnung
hoffnung im laufe des tages schmelzen
die 4000 franken dahin wie eis an der
afrikanischen sonne
peter cheret würde im fall einer wahl
nicht für gotteslohn arbeiten
er bekäme ein budget von rund einer
million franken und für sich selber
einen stattlichen lohn von 5000 franken
pro monat sehr viel geld in einem land
wie kenia aber darum gehe es ihm nicht
sagt peter scheel
[Musik]
ihm gehe es um die sache
zb im gesundheits und im bildungswesen
dank schweizer fehlt der technologie
soll das trinkwasser sauberer werden
alle kinder sollen eine schule besuchen
können und er plant kleine
gesundheitszentren jazz politisches
manifest ist umfangreich daneben lässt
er sich gerne mit pomp und gloria feiern
sechs gegner hat sie im wahlkampf
manchmal trifft er auf einen wie hier
sagt er sei der einzige mit
auslandserfahrung der einzige der nicht
korrupt sei der mann ist ein phänomen
einnehmend aber schwierig zu
durchschauen
vor fünf jahren probierte er es schon
einmal und verlor den wahlkampf diesmal
werde es klappen haben sie ja und amen
gesagt hat das ist die welt mir dass es
mehr anlasse drei viertel also ich hoffe
ganz schön dass es sie wird nie am antic
auf der vierte die welle
zwei tage vor der wahl erhält sie besuch
seine partnerin barbara vor ist
angereist um den wal showdown
mitzuerleben
kenia ist kein neuland mehr für die
schweizerin
sie hat peter cheret schon auf früheren
reisen begleitet das brach wert in das
dorf in dem sie es eltern bis zu ihrem
tod gelebt haben ja so viel auftrag
gegeben
zum steine abliefert bis jetzt warte ich
bis jetzt sind es keine auf dem land das
er geerbt hat wie schnee an
gemeindezentrum errichten
wir schätzen die chancen weil die gehört
und hier sind fantastisch und gewinnen
und da mal auf jeden fall und ich
einfach die seite vor der korruption
italy hätte also meeting zulauf so viele
tore und gegen noch in zum teil
unerschöpflich viel geld da weiß ja
nicht recht aber das waren ja war und
zum den abschätzen da wird wirklich eben
glauben wenn er rät den sind einem
nicken und dem freund und jetzt fühlen
und da wirklich eine woche ein trick ist
es lieber bringen aber wenn oder andere
die sich selig lernen habe weiß ich
nicht ob sie nicht immer noch nicht im
jetzt
oder will sie lieber zu fuß team jetzt
also war hüttig gilt und wann ich will
auch schon immer peter asché sagte kaufe
die stimmen nicht schließlich habe ja
keine kontrolle darüber ob diese
menschen tatsächlich auch wählen dennoch
unterstützte damit ein fragwürdiges
system
im momentan der leute das sind gewohnte
mit so viel mehr geld und ich kann nicht
auch weg wovon dieses system zu stehen
welche mir niemand oder da ich mir nicht
mehr ich leider ein bisschen ja mit der
musik die das warten
es ist notwendig wenn ich gewählt wird
da wird einfach ein bisschen hut vor der
leistung mit einfach nur locker 11 muss
einfach geistig denn gezahlt zuschnitt
der abfahrt aus der schweiz pflegt einen
lockeren umgang mit geld vor allem mit
fremdem geld wenn man seiner
geschiedenen frau in der schweiz glaubt
sie habe auch zur hauptsache dieses haus
in kenia bezahlt und habe erst nach
sieben jahren beziehung erzählt dass er
vier kinder hat was schließlich zum
bruch der beziehung führte nach der
scheidung aber die hälfte der
pensionskassen seiner frau bekommen geld
das er für seine beiden wahlkämpfe
einsetzen konnte sie selber ins ganze
vermögen angeht da war komplett steckt
und sie sagen wieviel das ewz will ich
hatte tolle und konzernkreise
das weg wie viel hätte eine cd wahlkampf
kostet ja nehmen wir halt bezeichnung
der 50 musiker wie kommt man denn aus
putz mal zu so viel geld seite so viele
leute wo hans mir einen vorschuss das
vielleicht eventuell muss sich herr ad
saale mit weniger zins oder soep ist
barbara vor hat ihren partner kein geld
gegeben aber sie hatten private darlehen
vermittelt und für ihn flüge bezahlt
damit er seinen traum verwirklichen kann
morgen entscheidet sich ob es gelingt
die wahllokale öffnen in der früh das
kenianische fernsehen berichtet nonstop
auch der präsident wird heute gewählt
barbara vorsitzt allein im hotel von
peter fäh keine spur
zwei journalisten und wie sie will die
bedeutet dass man bloß halt und sie
wünschte alle sony fluss und p i flow
sieg oder platz umsetzen
wir wollen sehen wie die bahn in einer
entlegenen region kenias vor sich gehen
und machen uns auf zu einem der
wahlkreise in dem sich peter cheret zur
wahl stellt ein schulhaus dient als
wahllokal
insgesamt gibt es 110 solche wahl
stellen im distrikt verschiedene ämter
sind neu zu besetzen
für jedes eine plastikbox dort hinein
kommen die stimmzettel der wählerinnen
und wähler
sie mussten sich zuvor registrieren um
18 uhr schließen die lokale es ist
wenige minuten davor eine markierung
soll verhindern dass jemand zweimal welt
es sind wichtige wahlen für kenia sie
verlaufen diesmal weitgehend friedlich
im gleichen lokal in dem gewählt wurde
werden etwas später die stimmen
ausgezählt
es gibt keinen strom eine gas lampe muss
genügen
vertreter der einzelnen parteien
überwachen die auszählung dann der
stapel mit peter cheret es stehen bloß
zehn stimmen für den schweizer abwehr
hat am wenigsten von allen sieben
kandidaten gemacht
doch als wir stehen seine getreuen
später treffen ist er keineswegs
deprimiert
telefonisch hat er das ergebnis aus
maria erfahren dort hat er am meisten
stimmen erzielt in der schweiz wie man
familie und freunde mit
wir sind in sicherheit
eine etwas größere schule dient das
stimmen zentrale hierher werden
sämtliche boxen aller 110 wahllokale
gebracht erstmals sollte für die
auszählung ein computer zum einsatz
kommen
doch das system bricht nach kurzer zeit
zusammen und stellt sich auf eine lange
nacht ein
20 stunden später dauert die auszählung
immer noch an
ohne eine pause lesen speaker die
stimmen aller kandidaten aus allen orten
und allen ämtern einzeln vor
[Musik]
die stimmen zu addieren überlässt man
dem publikum denen die nicht schlafen
nur eine hat den überblick
in der rechnung plötzlich aufregung
es gibt ungereimtheiten bei der
auszählung von peter heß stimmen
[Musik]
sie haben falsche informationen bekommen
es geht um einen ort in dem er angeblich
keine einzige stimme gemacht hat na ja
dass du das spiel stehen sie bekomme von
dead sind da einfach so viel liegt nicht
einmal eigenes schicksal bestimmen dass
das stimmt nicht
die auszählung geht unterdessen weiter
sie ist sich sicher dass ein wahlbetrug
vorliegt den will er beweisen nicht
umsonst hat er in jedem der 110
wahllokale einem beobachte postiert er
schickt zwei helferinnen los
zwei stunden vergehen dann ist sie im
besitz einer kopie des wahl- protokolls
aus dem umstrittenen ort und überreicht
diese den speaker
tatsächlich stimmen kopie und original
nicht überein aber was gilt nun
aus mangel an alternativen lässt der
wahl chef schließlich die beiden frauen
abführen die das neue papier besorgt
haben
ein paar stunden später sollten sie
wieder freigelassen werden allmählich
wendet sich das blatt zugunsten von
peter scheel immer mehr stimmen gewinnt
er in den folgenden stunden hinzu wenn
seine partnerin richtig gerechnet hat
kann ihm den sieg niemand mehr nehmen
über 6000 stimmen und fast 1000
vorsprung auf den nächsten verfolger
mit anbruch des tages steht peter
scheerer sieg fest
die stimmen aus dem wahlbetrug hat er
erhalten dahinter soll ein gegenkandidat
gesteckt haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich verspreche euch ich werde alle meine
beziehungen innerhalb und außerhalb
kenias nutzen um ganze zu helfen
im zweiten anlauf hat es tatsächlich
geschafft der abfahrt aus der schweiz
wird regierungschef des distrikts ganze
und vertreter im parlament von kenia
nach 24 jahren in der schweiz kehrt
peter cheret in seine alte heimat zurück
seine frau will ihn so oft wie möglich
besuchen die eigentliche bewährungsprobe
beginnt wenn die party vorbei ist dann
muss peter scheel beweisen dass es ihm
ernst ist mit seinen versprechen den
menschen ihr zu helfen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das mag